armored Core 6 will release on August
25th 2023. if it doesn't get delayed and
that is unfortunately a problem for
Alden Ring Hey guys Matt Luigi here and
in case you missed it armor core 6 did
get a release date announcement in
addition to a Gameplay trailer I really
like the Gameplay trailer if you haven't
seen it feel free to check it out it
showcases a few things from the game
that look sick and looks like it's going
to be a high energy Thrill Ride I'm very
excited for it but unfortunately this
means Elden Rings DLC shadow of the
erdtree will in all likelihood not be
coming out anytime soon we could be
waiting until winter of this year or
even sometime in 2024 for a release now
why am I saying this why is armored Core
6's release date dictating something
about Elden Ring's DLC while August is
only a few months away we're already
almost in May from software likely won't
want to put these two big releases very
close to each other the big new Revival
of the arm and Core Series and probably
the biggest DLC they've ever made which
is for the biggest game they've ever
made from software want one to take away
attention from the other they want to
spread them apart as far as they can so
they don't have to worry about an
audience for one taken away from the
audience for the other so that means
either the DLC could release right now
and that gives it a few months until
armored Core so that's plausible or it
could release at the earliest a few
months after armored Core drops and
attention starts to wane a little bit
which would put us into at least the
winter of this year now yeah from Salt
could do a surprise DLC drop right now
or sometime in the next week for example
but that would put it in direct
competition for attention with the new
Zelda game tears of the Kingdom in terms
of the playing experience and the
mechanics eldenring and Zelda are very
very different games but breath of the
wild and Elden ring are generally talked
about in the same breath when it comes
to absolutely massive open world Fantasy
games that are top of their class in
terms of being the game to beat and
raising the stakes for what the medium
can achieve breath of the wild and Elden
ring are two of the main contenders when
it comes to open world games so in some
ways Zelda is the only real competition
to Elden ring so it would be pretty
crazy to have the DLC drop right when
Zelda is coming out especially because
we haven't gotten any trailer for the
DLC and we would expect a trailer to
come out before the actual release more
Dev time to polish the DLC and make sure
armored core's launch goes well in
addition to not fighting the Behemoth
that is tears of the Kingdom seems like
the most sensible option for rumsov if
arm record doesn't get delayed and it
does launch on August 25th that means
over the next few months a lot of effort
at fromsoft is going to go into making
sure armored Core is ready to launch and
that the launch goes well so that
probably means no DLC for another 6 to
10 months maybe even longer of course
but that's our reasonable shorter
expectation window and that is a while
to wait which sucks but it does mean
that shadow of the archery can be
expected to be absolutely massive likely
larger in scale than any previous
soulsborne DLC this makes sense because
Elden ring is bigger than any previous
game and this DLC seems like it will
have had more development in time than
any previous DLC they've made so this is
obviously armored Core 6 news but in
some ways it is pretty big news for
Elden ring as well we were in 2022
wondering if the DLC could maybe come
out before 2023 and now we're looking at
the possibility of the DLC coming out in
2024. I'm Still Holding Out for winter
of this year since armored Core 6
releasing in August does still give a
few months of time for the Post launch
to go through and for them to prep the
DLC and release it in 2023 but it does
seem pretty likely that they could do
early 2024 as well I'll be continuing to
make Elder ring content in the meantime
but also probably hit up some other
games because we are in store for a long
wait I plan to cover armored Core and
might even cover some Zelda in the
meantime since it is a bit of a wait
till Armory core release and Zelda is
coming out in the next few weeks so if
that sounds interesting feel free to
stick around as I said I will still be
doing Eldon ring lore too so it's not
going to be a complete Elden ring
drought but if not then hunker down and
I'll see you when winter comes thanks
for watching peace